Michael Lewis your famous Finance author
can you explain how the FTX Ponzi scheme
happened this isn't a Ponzi scheme like
when you think of a Ponzi scheme I don't
know Bernie maid off the problem is it's
there's no real business there the
dollar coming in is being used to pay
the dollar going out and in this case
they actually had a great real business
if no one had ever cast aspersions on
the business if there hadn't been a run
on customer deposits they still be
sitting there making tons of money what
the are you talking about ladies and
gentlemen today is the first day of Sam
bakman Freed's criminal trial and
already we have books media tours going
on about it most notably from the
finance writer Michael Lewis who wrote
The Big Short Moneyball and now going
infinite which he says is a letter to
the jury about the true story of what
happened with FTX you had so much access
to Sam bankman freed writing this book
what ultimately is is the purpose here I
realized I had an ambition for the book
I saw it as a kind of letter to the jury
I mean there's going to be this trial
and the lawyers are going to tell two
stories and so there's a story war going
on in the courtroom and I think neither
one of those stories is as good as the
story I have now I decided to read that
story so you don't have to because
historically these letters to the jury
haven't gone all that great and turns
out this one is no different I had to
sit through hundreds of pages of Sam
worship a a fantic 60 Minutes interview
talking about what a great business FTX
was and I was only left with one
question what is it about Sam bankman
freed that makes Smart people go nuts
well I decided to investigate I wondered
is it the Bahamas sea salt air is it
effective altruism or is it a $40
million
Penthouse I think I've got a guess which
is why I'm here in the $40 million
Bahama Penthouse now I know many of you
have questions how did you afford this
the truth is I low balled him with ftt
tokens and the seller was very motivated
so this will be my new base of
operations for finding the truth about
SPF and we're going to start by looking
at one of the last supporters of Sam
Michael Lewis and yes the coconut came
with the
penthouse to understand this interview
frankly the whole book you need to know
that Michael Lewis started it as like a
positive story about CM before FTX
collaps right it was supposed to be a
crypto like rag to Rich's story about
how dreams really do come true but of
course then they committed fraud and
collapsed and so everyone kind of
naturally thought oh yeah he'll just
change the book actually kind of an
interesting twist except the book didn't
change 75% of the book just doesn't
mention anything about fraud uh when
Michael Lewis does get to the collapse
he just believes Sam bankman freed about
everything unquestioningly like it's so
bad that Sam bankman freed wouldn't even
trust himself that much literally Sam is
quoted in Michael's book saying and I do
think this is a red flag quote in a lot
of ways I don't really have a soul in
the end there's a pretty decent argument
that my empathy is fake my feelings are
fake and my facial reactions are fake
now compare and contrast that to Michael
Lewis describing Sam as the things he
was telling me all of which I should say
here turned out to be true was
incredible so even s SPS believes in SBF
less than Michael Lewis does this man is
a oneman cheerleader team you've
literally got the subject of your book
saying I have no soul and my reactions
are fake and then the writer just goes
this may be the most honest man I've
ever met believing this requires so much
willful ignorance on the part of Michael
Lewis that it borderlines on malpractice
take for instance Dan fredberg spf's
lawyer who we explained as a history of
covering up fraud before for FTX does
Michael Lewis mention this at all no let
me share with you some of the ways Dan
fredberg is talked about here's some
quotes in Sam's World Dan Friedberg in
his early 50s has been the only
important grown-up he was ftxs General
Counsel he was also the babysitter he'd
sort of gotten swept up by the
enthusiasm of the effective altruists I
wanted to be a Sam as he put it and by
the way being a Sam was a huge
compliment to Michael a lot of people
wanted there to be a Sam you know there
is still a Sam bankman freed shaped hole
in the world that now needs filling like
that character would be very useful what
he represented what he wanted to do with
the resources the irony here is again
you know who is more skeptical of Dan
Friedberg than Michael Lewis Sam bakman
freed how do I know this well I got an
audio recording from Tiffany Fong a
reporter we've talked to before who's
been talking to Sam hey coffee so while
talking to Sam in April I discovered he
was aware Dan friberg's past although he
stops short of explicitly accusing him
of committing crimes well everyone
thought that Dan fredberg was very
clearly sketchy so it was very shocking
that he was hired at FTX so he's an
interesting guy um um because what was
he in with ultimate vets or something
like that yeah something like that it
wasn't quite ultimate vets but it's
something like
that reputation was like that he was
really shady or something like that yeah
he did have a somewhat Shady reputation
um he's uh
uh he's a very good lawyer he's
extremely productive um he had extremely
good instincts and he would take care of
problems that like other lawyers would
not think to take care of or not know
how to take care of so even Sam bankman
free doesn't try to deny Dan's Shady
reputation and said Dan would take care
of things other lawyers wouldn't like
even the guy on tribe is like all right
I have to admit he's pretty sketchy so
it's insane to watch Michael Lewis put
zero skepticism into the characters of
FTX is collapse but then watch this
contrast that with how much skepticism
Michael Lewis brings to the bankruptcy
lawyer John Ray like the guy who's taken
over the collapse now that FTX is
bankrupt quote John Ray expected to see
evidence of a crime instead of answering
the question Ray launched a blitz Creek
of lawsuits against various people to
whom Sam had Ed Money the pleasure Ray
took in whatever he Unearthed was so
infectious that I often didn't have the
heart to say I'm not quite sure that you
found exactly what you think you found
so every step of the way he's just like
yeah this guy doesn't know what he's
talking about but Sam bankman freed it's
so unbelievably condescending the way
this book interrogates everyone who had
to clean up the FTX mess instead of the
you know people responsible but worse
Michael Lewis casts himself as like the
only truth teller we've all been in the
dark but thanks to this man's Mighty
powers of the pin he's going to reveal
the truth that nobody knew the story of
Sam's life is people not understanding
him misreading him he's so different
he's so unusual I mean I think in a
funny way that the reason I have such a
compelling story is I have a character
that I do come to know and then the
reader comes to know that the world
still doesn't know Hey guys you're being
really mean to Sam don't you know he's
really misunderstood did I mention what
a good guy he is yet uh he really cares
about pandemics and saving democracy
sand bankman fre ends up with a
portfolio heavily concentrated in two
things pandemic prevention because there
really are things the government should
be doing he took the view that all the
big existential problems are going to
require the United States government to
be involved to solve them and if the
democracy is undermine it like we don't
have our democracy anymore all these
problems are less likely to be solved I
have no idea why we're talking about Sam
like he's on trial for the Nobel Peace
Prize instead of fraud the part that
annoys me the most is Michael Lewis
doesn't admit the fact that for all the
talk about giving the effective altruism
really didn't happen you know what did
happen paying celebrities stupid sums of
money so he could hang out with them he
paid Tom Brady $55 million for 20 hours
a year for three years he paid Steph
Curry $35 million for same thing for 3
years pretty good hourly W he spent
hundred and something million dollars
buying the naming rights for the Miami
Heat arena I don't think so he spent $25
million making a Super Bowl ad with
Larry David it's
FTX I don't think so for which he then
paid Larry David another $10 million you
know it's breathtaking what's on that
list I don't know what's so breathtaking
about that how does this qualify as like
this guy's such an altruist you paid a
guy $50 million for 20 hours of work and
let's not forget by the way part of that
money came from customers deposits so
just understand as we go into this court
case you're going to hear some people
try to say that Sam is an innocent
well-meaning altruist who bumbled his
way into losing 8 billion um of course
we all know that isn't true and the
people who are suggesting it it seems
are allergic to basic research and do
not extend the same levels of sympathy
that they extend to Sam to the actual
victims who they think are just gamblers
anyways I can see people watching this
saying like come on guys this is
Elizabeth Holmes and cargo shorts and
this is all a Roose don't fall for the
stick this is a bad actor it is a little
different supplying you know phony
medical information to people that might
kill them and in this case what you're
doing is possibly losing some money that
belonged to crypto speculators in the
Bahamas on the other hand this is not to
excuse he shouldn't have done that yeah
you kind of are excusing it you know ah
it was just a few specul in the Bahamas
who lost money no it wasn't you know
regular people are owed money that's
kind of the whole point of this thing
partially because of all of those
influencers who were hired whether it be
on YouTube Sports influencers they
weren't just appealing to the Bahamas
those Super Bowl ads didn't play in The
Bahamas play in the United States baby
this whole interview got me as you can
tell a little bit steamed which then
made me read the book cuz I was like you
know probably the book's better but that
actually made me more angry and it
literally put me back to work on this
case I'd been working on a different
project thinking uh you know the S SPF
stuff is kind of open shut the normal
Finance writers can handle it but I was
wrong so I'm back I'll be watching this
case like a hawk and you know we'll be
covering it for the $40 million Bahama
pin housee but I may even fly up to New
York just to make sure there's no funny
business make sure Michael Lewis isn't
in the courtroom petitioning the jury
for a lighter sentence on his baby Sam
anyways that's it for me Case Closed uh
one
[Music]
star